my dad was just a dad like you know for
a while there's three boys he's a single
dad he's raising all of us he's working
doubles he doesn't have time like part
of life you're gonna have to learn on
your own you're not gonna be able to be
walked through every moment of your life
it's like the opposite of what my mother
said she said I'll always be here to
walk you to every moment our house was
for guys so I have two brothers my dad
and we had a one bathroom and my dad was
just he had an artful way of teaching
you a valuable lesson art while
humiliating you at the same time and
foot there was one night where I was in
the shower and I was laying down giving
myself what I thought was a solid
lovemaking session mm-hmm where you laid
down yeah
seventh grade but you mare menteng with
myself and air men thing I love that
I've never it's never occurred to me to
be like you know what I'm gonna pretend
she's on top
he's in the rain I never this rain
fantasy we're in the rain and
she's on top cause she likes to give it
to me sometimes it was it was
comfortable now uh-huh and I got up when
I was finished and I got up quick and I
got a head rush and I grabbed the shower
curtain and it just ripped away wrapped
around me like it was as scared as I was
the fall out of the tub and I went down
I'm yelling for help
and my father came in and he opened the
door he's like Oh Mike and then he
yelled Derrick Todd he called both my
brothers to come to the door and when
they came to the door I'm like oh my I'm
like dad come on dad and he said look at
your brother he said remember when you
guys asked me if you could go blind for
masturbating well you can't but this can
happen oh Polaroid yellow bags now you
learned your lesson